we've been discussing
for a long time but in particular since
the november election
is there anything that could get a
really committed
trumpist to realize the error of their
ways
and to change their minds and to realize
that they've been fueling the problem
in which the united states now finds
itself
and i get many calls like this from
viewers who say i don't know how to talk
to
my aunt or my significant other or my
parents or whoever else
and it's a very difficult thing and my
advice is usually pretty general in
nature
but it can happen at least in theory
a supposed uh a a supposed
trumpist called c-span in tears
apparently realizing or at least
suspecting
that she had been lied to by donald
trump and
uh she goes by tammy in boise idaho
this could be fake we don't know i mean
it's impossible to really know this
could be some kind of troll but
it certainly appears to be real take a
listen to tammy from idaho in tears
as she realizes trump
may have lied to her what are your
thoughts about today i just have one
question
i wanted to know if my president lied to
me today
and if he did i want me him to tell me
and more importantly
i want him to tell the family of the
woman that
got shot and killed today i voted for
him
i voted for him
and sorry
that's tammy and boise so there are many
reasons to be curious about whether
this is legit you and i might be saying
how could
anyone doubt trump has been lying all
along obviously he's been lying all
along
but the reality is that tens of millions
don't realize or haven't yet realized
that donald trump has been lying about
everything all along including over the
last two months
acutely so about supposed voter fraud
but
assuming that this caller is genuine and
that this is someone starting to see how
they've fallen for it
understand that they've been bamboozled
not just by trump
but they've all also been bamboozled by
fox news
and the other right-wing media and and
that apparatus
and by other republicans as well so if
this is real
i get all of these calls where people
say how do i talk to these people how do
i change their minds
if and when people reach the moment that
tammy reached
this is when we talk to them about
coming back to reality this is the
opportunity if
if anyone you know is fortunate enough
to reach a moment
like tammy appears to have reached
that's when you swoop in and say
yes he's been lying i'm so glad you see
it
come on back let's figure it out and
work together to prevent it from
happening again
you don't go you idiot of course that's
what's been going on now we're all
thinking it
and you know in a platform like this to
some degree it's like of course you
fools
how did you not know it but for
everybody who's been asking me
how do you do it what do you do on a
personal level what do you do when the
opportunity presents itself you say
welcome back he lied to he lied to all
of us let's never let this happen again
and most people
aren't ready to accept this most of you
aren't going to get someone at tami's
stage
of realizing what has happened i don't
know how you force it i don't know that
you can
i think there's something sort of about
one's predisposition and constitution
whether you just in the face of
contradictory evidence you double down
and double down and double down
uh and some folks are more predisposed
to hear reason
maybe hearing from republicans that they
trust or used to trust
like you know mitt romney arnold
schwarzenegger had a great video
that he put up over the weekend chris
christie has now bailed
maybe they are going to
help turn some of these folks back to
reality
uh and make them ready to understand how
they've been bamboozled i don't know
and so understand that this is not about
empathizing with these people
necessarily they have been part of one
of the most toxic
political movements in the history of
the united states tens of millions of
them are nowhere near ready to abandon
it like tammy is
don't concern yourself with forgiveness
or empathy
the evidence of trump's lies has been
there forever
i know it you know it but if we can get
them back then we should do it it should
be approached from a pragmatic
standpoint and one of the real lessons
of trumpism
has been how easy it is to fool massive
groups of people
we knew it in cults for example the jim
jones people's temple but that was
900 people who went to guyana
and ultimately drank the arsenic-laced
kool-aid but here we're talking about
tens of millions of people
and we've seen the bamboozling
at minimum and i spoke about this uh uh
or i will speak about it with peter
joseph who we're going to be
interviewing
we've seen it since the reagan era the
non-existent
welfare queen uh who's hanging around
uh um driving a cadillac i think it is
um as she pops out kids to make great
profits from food stamps and welfare
benefits it was non-existent then
and it's built and built and built and
the last four years have confirmed that
yeah it's possible to fool
way more people about way more obviously
untrue things so there are lessons here
about
cults there are lessons here about mass
brainwashing
a lot of this is mental health as well
but it's not
right or or proper to say these are just
crazy people but there's a mental health
component here as well
we've learned about how ignorance can be
quite literally weaponized
if you don't believe i mean listen okay
there's people out there who just have
bloodlust and even if they don't believe
the election was stolen they hear trump
saying let's go to the capitol
they say great it's an opportunity to to
get involved in violence okay
the vast majority of these folks though
if they don't fall for it was stolen
they're not going to go to the capitol
and riot
because it because someone is saying
that it was stolen in other words the
the ignorance
and the disinformation that has been
promulgated and perpetuated by trump and
the people around him
was literally weaponized into a riot
that's the the way we have to understand
that and so
tammy if this is legit good for her i
know that there are anecdotal stories
from people in my audience of similar
things that have happened but
i think that as much as we would like
everybody to have an awakening like
tammy did and sort of
be open to being being given some some
reality some
facts uh if it took 40 years to get into
this we're talking about
you know at least a decade of
significant working towards social
change eight to ten years and
it's not realistic to imagine that in an
in a democracy or something at least
approximating one
that type of change is going to happen
really quickly it's just not if it takes
a long time to get in it's going to take
some time to get out